damn bro
that's intense i like the energy i love
it bro reality is
look you could never be comfortable look
you know anything about sports i know
everything about sports what's your
favorite sport
basketball who's your favorite player of
all time lebron james okay
lebron jay who's he chasing michael
jordan he want to be the best ever
even though he got the rings even though
he got the records the minutes play
boom he chasing why because he's not
settling
you get it he was from the cavs
to the miami to the cavs to l.a
kobe died they [ __ ] on him because
kobe got muriels and he was like oh [ __ ]
jordan never lost it's like oh my god
lebron
the bro yo lebron he ain't gonna get it
there until everybody recognizes him
what other sport you like
golf golfer who's your favorite golfer
uh
john daly john daly hit the ball 400
yards
big [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] san
francisco california oh [ __ ]
yo careful character all right is that
still good
is that in we good is the camera good
my camera he just hit my camera oh [ __ ]
i need to go to the left
you just pull it towards you a little
bit you're good good
all right so tell me when you're ready
so john daly right
good are we good are we good we good
yeah so john d
i'm at the cow palace in san francisco
yeah 1996.
i see a guy selling baseball cards he
got a rolex prezi with a red face you
can look at him on sports illustrated
it was john's yo i had to buy that watch
no stop it bro of course i swear to god
stretch like a [ __ ] do you still
have it no i push it i push everything
oh man the watches i keep are [ __ ] i
like i got like 10 watches that's it
because i need to buy and sell i got to
i got to feed the excitement
if i don't feed the excitement i'm not
doing it you know that [ __ ]
drinks like 28 diet cokes a day
john
who's your favorite player my favorite
football player of all time
uh marshawn lynch beastmode went to
buffalo
he went then he went to seattle he
should have ran the ball
they could have beat brady and russell
wilson a second ring
encyclopedia okay give me the next sport
give me another any player you got
any sport any player any sport any
players baseball you know
baseball i don't know [ __ ] about
baseball oh yeah i like uh i like uh
who's the [ __ ] baseball guy who used
to fight everybody nolan ryan i like him
bro he came up in 1968 his rookie car
got jerry kuzmin on it 1968 tops card
number
177. he was clocked out at 100.8 miles
an hour
he bro imagine this he threw seven no
hitters never won a cy young 324 wins
most strikeouts of all time the illest
his name is lynn nolan ryan what holy
mario lemieux pittsburgh penguins oh
come on b
mario lemieux had hodgkin's disease he
was making so much money that the
pittsburgh pain was going to give him
the team
besides gretzky he was the illest player
of all time he had kevin stevens and
jeremy yaga to win rings yeah who else
who else let's go
[ __ ] i don't know i can't stump you now
i'm
troy palamalu oh come on come
daddy he played for pittsburgh they
wanted and they wanted tampa
when they beat the arizona cardinals bro
safety the illest
he was he just played the field who else
kelly slater who oh you talk about saved
by the belt
no pro surfer [ __ ] i don't freak with
that
you don't break my surface no not really
because i i seen that one movie where
the chick lost her hand but
you know what hold on surfing what about
jess piccoli fast times that richard
hell yeah well yeah what about keanu
reeves
oh of course bro the matrix but anyway
the whole point is b
you got to be well versed you got to
know a little bit about everything
you got to be able to hold the
conversation what about steph curry oh
come on the illest three-point shooter
of all time
bro the reason he didn't sign did you
watch the game last night
i remember in the first quarter he hit
some shot that was ill will but i'm not
really i don't i don't really freak with
basketball i'm a knicks fan
and the knicks back in the head like i
found the knicks when they had patrick
ewing
charles oakley mark brown the ill squad
you come down the middle you're going to
get wrecked yeah
so like since who's better lebron or
jordan
greatest of all time who's the goat
lebron but to me the best is not even
none of those
who's the best the best of all times
will chamberlain look his moves up
wilton still
oh you still look him up he [ __ ] more
[ __ ] than anybody that's what i heard
100 points
the whole point is yeah we played for
syracuse had 100 points but the point is
when you look and then you look at range
look at bill russell
right but jordan got to be better
he has to be better than lebron because
he played in a better
um talent pool you know what i'm saying
when you look at the talent
and he knows what he never had to play
the golden state warriors though
yeah people draw it up you gotta miss kd
no no i get it i get it but they lost to
katie twice though
lebron lost to katie twice so jordan was
6-0
and then he took a two-year hiatus they
won three lost two and played baseball
yeah the point is i can't really i can't
really say anybody's better than jordan
since 85 because he's undefeated in
championships
and the whole world knows jordan jordan
is a brand uh beyond a brand it's like
this you know jay-z was like
i'm not a businessman i am the
businessman
so basically jordan is the game yeah
jordan is the hustle he's the game
right but let's get back to real estate
because that's my game that's my hustle
real estate what else are we going to
hold about i don't know i'm ready to go
buy something and sell it right now
what about woke up in this piece oh man
i'm [ __ ] ready what about cards
what's your most expensive i think i
asked you last time like i want to know
i got jordan 10's 86 flare id i got
i got mickey mantle rookies 51 bowman mc
i got willie mays rookies i got
ty cobbs t206 greenbacks i got gold back
tycoons i got walter johnson's
i got um christy matthewson's i got i
got um
you got me with you no i didn't bring
any cards [ __ ]
what about pokemon cards no i don't
freak with that i don't know [ __ ] about
that
you don't know that's not my thing dude
bro this is not my gig some people make
millions on pokemon go
i could understand there's money in that
game this is not my house what about the
sneaker game
yeah my boys my boy yo the illest
sneaker man in the whole country
let me tell you a little story about my
man jc lopez jc lopez what's the deal
with tim bro
jc lopez is the eldest [ __ ] ever
lived i'm gonna tell you why
this guy's from jersey where i grew up
he owns a sneaker store called urban
necessities you heard of it
yeah you told me about it all right so
this kid grew up
from zero they dropped him off in vegas
my cousin tobin
he didn't even have money for food this
guy had a dream
and he's like yo no matter what i'm
gonna get here
now he's the ill bro honestly i'ma tell
you why i love him
he came here he came here like six seven
years ago right so
he grew up with my cousins candace who
runs my company
my cousin paco her twin brother and her
and my cousin angel right
and my cousin toby right they all grew
up toby on the um
he owned the bail bonds jc worked with
him and he grew up with my other cousins
boom he comes here one day and they're
like yo let's go out to eat
so i'm like i'm like where are you at
the casino so i'm not i'm thinking
though i gotta eat the steak i swear
like four or five hours i'm not beat
let's go to the let's go to the um
let's go to this upstairs to the to the
um to the um buffet
they got good i don't care you know what
i mean food don't matter to me i eat
i eat to live i don't live to eat get it
so he's like brownie steakhouse boom i'm
alright whatever
and he said bro you remember one time
you told me that they ain't money in
this [ __ ]
i'm like i don't remember you told me
that's why i'm a crying you know when he
told me that
i wanted to cry now when i go see him
sitting all night
the illest sneakers of all time that's
my story on sneakers
and i got a couple friends of mine here
they own sneaker stores i got involved
with them
it's a hard hustle it's not really my
gig when i when i figured out
the work i had to do it's just too much
work it's a lot of work
any game that has a lot of work to do
that you don't get big big zeros
on a closing yeah yeah you're going big